and some breaking news now a ukrainian
court has sentenced a russian soldier to
life in prison for killing an unarmed
civilian it is the first war crime trial
arising from russia's invasion the 21
year old soldier have pleaded guilty to
charges including pre-mediated murder
and committing a war crime during a
trial in kiev it's the first war crime
trial held and is likely to be one of
many the young sergeant admitted he shot
dead a
year old civilian on a bicycle in the
eastern sumi region on february the 28th
ukraine's prosecutor general says it is
investigating nearly 11 000 potential
war
crimes dw's max sander joins me now from
the courthouse in kiev
max a verdict of life in prison has just
been announced what more can you tell us
right so this verdict really didn't come
as a surprise the uh
um
the defendant uh 21 year old sergeant
vadim shushi marine already pled guilty
last week
but it took the
judge the presiding judge nevertheless
almost an hour to present the case
present the evidence
and at the end of which he found this
man guilty of violating laws and customs
of war and as you said he's
he has been found guilty of killing a 62
year old man in the sumi region
and a
crucial part of the the reason for for
this sentence is that
vadim shishi marine the sergeant did not
receive technically did not receive an
order to do so but he was pressured into
doing this by a higher ranking soldier
who he was traveling with in a seized
civilian vehicle out of fear that this
man could report their presence to the
ukrainians right and um the court argues
that uh this sergeant would have not had
to do so and he would not have and
feared any have to fear any consequences
if he had uh not given in to the
pressure by his comment but we're also
hearing that the defense
will launch an appeal
now the fighting in donbass has shifted
to the city of zebra donetsk in recent
days ukraine is struggling to hold on to
it
do you think that the city could become
another mario pole
i mean there are fears that this could
become the situation there yes russia
has been pushing forward with
all they have in the southeastern
territories in of of ukraine in the
donbass region
but sevilla donetsk is a bit different
than mario paul because this is very
close to the front line after the 2014
invasion
where russian state-backed rebels have
been holding large swaths of territory
ever since so this city is actually
better prepared than mario pole but
nevertheless the russians are showing
with heavy shelling with air strikes and
with china taking neighboring villages
that they are seriously trying to
encircle and perhaps lay siege to that
town
and why is severe uh donetsk so
important for the russians
well the town is of strategic importance
it's one of the largest uh towns in that
area and secondly it's the last uh
stronghold of the ukrainian forces it's
the last pocket of defense so to say and
the russians have claimed after they
were not able have taken kiev and the
large parts of the country they're
shifting their focus to the southeast
that they would uh focus now on donbass
and luhansk and luhans this is actually
the last city that is in control of the
ukrainians so taking it would bring the
russians further to their acclaimed goal
that they would uh so to say
in their eyes liberate these areas all
right max sander they're reporting for
us from kiev thank you so much max